all right guys gather around time for  the week fourteen playoff picture  hey hey B what do you like better Gucci  steampunk waka a prep school boy with a  secret I don't know they both look  pretty stupid  Antonia kill me with my top E tail hey  God how do I look be honest you know  blue average serviceable I guess but  what are you gonna do with this boy dope  dope okay Alex Smith move a little  further to your left further further  perfect okay guys enough silly photos  long shots out let's get the real  playoff teams back in here  Xavier Rhodes can you go a little to  your right you're covering Julio damn  right I excuse me am I even in this  thing no not really  okay on three everyone let's say the  Jags really hey nah uh-uh bills guy you  get up just five quick will you just sit  next to the other bench quarterbacks Eli  we're the same at kill me okay almost  done let's just do realistic contenders  only so Titans you're out Jags out what  Lions definitely out and smile